people forget how bad things were
particularly for black
men under obama in terms of employment
the black unemployment rate
did not fall below double digits until
the seventh year
of the obama presidency so things were
very bad for a very long
time and then under trump we see record
low
unemployment rates record low poverty
rates
we see the wages rising for the least
skilled workers
at the fastest rate of all workers
things were going quite well pre-covered
in terms of the economy and and and and
kovid really shut all that down and i
think trump's focus
on reopening and getting people back to
work is one reason he improved his
numbers
uh among minorities
you mentioned just sort of generally the
state of race relations that they got
worse under obama you feel they got
worse under trump and now here we are
with
with this new ideology that seemingly
will only make it worse when you when
you say got
worse what how do you actually define
that because i find when i
the limited amount that i've traveled in
the last year because of covid but
from talking to my audience and hearing
what people are saying when i do get to
travel
i think most people don't really care
about race i don't think people really
care about sexuality i certainly don't
think they care about gender
i think americans probably something
like 80 percent of them are kind of live
and let live
they just don't know it exactly it's not
the messaging they get
how do you actually grade sort of okay
it got worse under obama or it got worse
under trump well i'm i'm basing that on
polling data
uh gallup poll asked this question every
few years
uh do you think race relations have
improved or worsened
and uh when obama left office in
um in 2015 um
or 2016 i should say um
the the that pole answer showed that
race relations were at their lowest
point
since the early 90s um so they had
really really tapered off
and and they didn't improve much under
trump at least in terms of how people
were responding
to that question now there there could
be um
something in the way the question is
asked or framed or something
and maybe anecdotally uh it's easy
uh to to counter that notion i mean if
uh
you know intermarriage rates are up uh
you know if um um things like that are
going on
if there's less segregation uh in in a
in in residential housing and so forth
um
that would all you know point in the
opposite direction so it may be a way of
how the question is framed
but i'm basing it on the polling the
polling data that i've read yeah and
then at the same time we see
interesting things like i think it was
black female support i think doubled
for trump uh than than four years prior
we saw the blexit movement
we did see some markers that things are
kind of changing
but i sense now it could all be for
naught
i i think we saw some some indications
that
there's no reason for the republican
party to give up on the minority vote
uh trump improved his his performance uh
among blacks especially among hispanic
voters
and i think that had a lot to do with
his
focus on reopening the economy uh after
covid i mean
people forget how bad things were
particularly for black
men under obama in terms of employment
the black unemployment rate
did not fall below double digits until
the seventh year
of the obama presidency so things were
very bad for a very long
time and then under trump we see record
low
unemployment rates record low poverty
rates
we see the wages rising for the least
skilled workers
at the fastest rate of all workers
things were going quite well pre-covered
in terms of the economy and and and and
kovid really shut all that down and i
think trump's focus
on reopening and getting people back to
work is one reason he improved his
numbers
uh among minorities yeah so before we
jump into
to the doc and and uh thomas all and all
that
let's do a little bit on on the right
side of things um
i think a lot of people that are
watching this probably agreeing with
your assessment of what's going on on
the left
what do you make of what's going on on
the right right now like do you think
trump
is gonna you know lead some sort of
patriot party now what happens to
establishment
republicans can they reconcile all of
this stuff
well um who who knows what donald trump
is going to do
i mean i've stopped i've stopped
trying to guess about his intentions uh
it may be limited
what in what he can do depending on on
how this impeachment process
plays out uh i guess mitch mcconnell has
made some
some comments uh that some to believe
that he would vote for conviction and
others say that
if if he does others will follow suit
and if the senate convicts him
in a way that prevents them from running
for office again then that could
quash efforts going forward i guess he
could still have influence in terms of
of endorsing people or so forth or
funding
uh movements but um but in terms of
personally
and his own political career that could
that could probably be the uh the the
nail in the
in the coffin on that yeah it does seem
like you know
the quote-unquote swamp is is sort of
ready to just circle and and expunge him
but what do you do with those 74 million
people i guess that's really the
question well
yeah he's he's he's got his followers
uh we don't know what will happen with
them some of them were people that were
not politically active at all he made
them
uh uh come out and come out and
participate in politics for the first
time so
could they go back to being inactive
again um
some of a lot of them and the left
doesn't like to acknowledge this but a
lot of them were former obama voters
that he won
in in 2016 and me and held on to
in 2020 yeah um so uh what will become
of of those voters uh without trump
but you know yes you know the republican
party is worried about losing some of
those
some of those trump voters but i also
think and i don't know
how they compare in terms of numbers but
i can say there are also a fair number
of republicans
like my wife for instance who could
never bring herself to support
donald trump she didn't like the way he
talked about women or
demean the war record of military heroes
and so forth
so um she did not uh support republicans
while he was in office but she's
perfectly ready to go back to supporting
republican presidential candidates now
so i don't know how representative she
is
uh of of people out there so who who who
knows
how how this will play out um but um
i think it's clear that the country um
may have been tired of donald trump
but uh they they voted for divided
government they they shrunk
uh the the democrats lead in the house
uh we have a 50-50 senate
um so the country
is not throwing out republicanism with
with donald trump and and i think that's
something biden
should keep in mind uh as he goes
forward governing
yeah if i mean in my humble opinion if
he if he goes down the identity politics
route that it seems like he's going
down they're gonna get crushed even
harder in two years which
probably would be good to balance things
out but well
the the the i i think you know obama
made this mistake when he came into
office
and maybe joe biden will learn from it
but i think um
they saw george w bush with very low
approval ratings going out of office and
they interpreted that as a mandate
for a far left agenda so they passed the
stimulus package they didn't do much
and then they turned their their their
their attention to reforming
transforming the health care system in
this country in a highly partisan
fashion uh and it turned out to be
hugely unpopular
they lost in time both houses of
congress the democrats did
and it turned it turned out to be a
disaster and it'll be interesting to
know if biden interprets trump's
unpopularity
with a mandate for moving forward with a
progressive agenda
uh i don't think people were were voted
for him for
a progressive agenda uh so i i i we'll
we'll see if
if joe biden learned anything from the
last time he was in the white house
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell